Pam my team's app is awesome it is
awesome really sighs how about this look
at this just a playmaker in the money
abhi Alisa but where does it I'll meet
you at the top so we're seeing some
pretty good defense here in the first
quarter only Stein like that you know
like Kings basketball buddy hield
stepped in front of the passing lane
turnover
that's pitch walk turnover from Miami
let's see if the Kings can capitalize
yes they will be elite set to the open
Willie cauley-stein three-point game how
about that play Mason and cauley-stein
working the two-man game hey nobody's
played solo tonight he does have five
assists but he could have had six there
speaking of assists Willie with a chance
for one more Shumpert knocked it away
cauley-stein with the block look at
Shump
good effort and now it's finally taken
by a sacrifice
[Music]
beginning yeah the elites is the one
that got a hand on it
now seven on the clock bunny hill
setting up takes a lot of time off the
clock thirty fields fine and Willie
cauley-stein up top with the throw down
throw it up I trow it down with some
good opportunities and now they have a
three on one the other way P elite
sub-block towns that are getting you
started nice play by Sacramento and
cauley-stein doing it all here in the
first half he's got 11 free throws when
we come back
[Music]
what a setup that was
drastically sees things on a whole
nother level Willie takes it up top and
throw it down in there with our stats
all the offense Minnesota's health muddy
healed the deer and boxers by buying
seven points shepherd what a pass
Willie cauley-stein now with 19 but how
about some bear beautiful here as we
watch them get inside just drop this off
beautifully boardvision does long so
fall yes
[Applause]
[Music]
but he dials in go-go-gadget says Willie
but you're gonna have to knock him down
Willie century 659 go-go gadget
Willie cauley-stein down Main Street
delivering high above the tin nicely
done by we'll see Rudy though
Colbert he had his hands in his pockets
kind of another guy now I'm not gonna be
a [ __ ] airplay on the Kentucky who's
been terrific to bit jump from his first
year put on the pitch inside a movie
called Stone Hill sweat it out chance
here for Sacramento yes it is and that's
exactly what Scott Foster just told Dave
Yeager right here here and down he'll
come over and help me I hope my teammate
Willie delivers at the basket
beautifully done by Darren Fox and
Willie cauley-stein well actually in the
West Pacers need to stop Fox
Harley Stein goes to the other side he's
sliding to the other side miles can't
get there for the block
[Music]
what a setup mo connivance Macaulay's
done and again de Villegas so good
[Applause]
know what a pass to cauley-stein Oh take
it to the roof and drop it off
Willie hood right here beautiful pick
and roll you don't catch me but I guess
it will be says think
[Music]
shot
24-second clock cauley-stein where do
you put it Willie Oh
drop me a shovel pass I know what to do
with it up top duck your head up Willie
cauley-stein and it's a 1:15 Paul he's
dying oh boy
Willie cauley-stein and its 1:16 to 1:07
another assist for Fox the Fox code oh
dear and Fox put on a platter
can you play any better than the Aaron
Fox tonight Jackson now it was a crowd
cauley-stein to the basket
surprising that they would go to double
JJ and a halfway point C JJ go away from
the pic draw the double team will he
knows exactly what to do with it climb
in the ladder that's everything for
winning the best 6556 nice ball by
cauley-stein what a plot to take big has
got to be offensive soldiers and gets a
rejection there that's a two-on-one
banovitz and there's some defense into
offense by Willie cauley-stein the
Lakers all up thinking of his
goaltending
here's box hanging wild shot know you
want to
Ingram blocked by cauley-stein a thing
of beauty
here we go the other way it's a
four-on-three fox pegs and scores the
box the one thing there's a theme to
this story first of all you get me we're
going now though comes to Chandler
cauley-stein and oh oh boy a timeout by
baby a good he had already decided the
call at the Kings had a two-on-one
I like that hard cut right there about
the yeren Fox
nice pass the elite said the Polish time
the interior pass in pneumonia with the
dime interior passing granted a premium
put it on the deck find my man Willie up
top this is how you win because he
didn't complain he just goes down and
let's lift me up again 100 to 90 to box
setting up cauley-stein beautifully
Justin Jack said in those 16 minutes he
was outstanding yes he will five be
elites up cauley-stein Oh get on like
this game you don't like NBA basketball
bringing the ball up be respect to three
I drop it and Willie knows what to do
trot down beautiful beautiful vision
right there by pneumonia Jackson now on
curry Thompson picked off by pops he
read it beautifully Pauly Stein
tie ball game take it to the top Gordon
starts out on Bogdanovich finds the open
cauley-stein you wanted to assist you
got one bogey with an opening again it's
Willie cauley-stein nicely done by bold
Dom's
[Music]
and a beautiful setup cauley-stein
nanus loves to shoot that ball and
Jackson recovered nicely oh my goodness
Willie is just blocking everything
coming into the paint and Buddy knows
what to do
spread them Daniels into the lane
cauley-stein another reduction Willie a
beautiful set up by deer and Fox and the
Kings have the lead back Andre Drummond
blocked by cauley-stein
the elites up all he finds the open
Willie cauley-stein third row how about
that huh yes Willie cauley-stein not
giving up on the play blocking that one
with this left hand and passing the ball
right back how about that and a chance
for a three-point play
bottom misses don't jump what do you
think it Willie
up above put him in the [ __ ] and one
thank you very much mr. Stein two times
on the offensive board giving your
team's multiple opportunities now beyond
boat blocked by cauley-stein and they
have a jump ball and the anything slide
helps on the defensive end comes back
gets his man and just stuffed some right
at the basket nice pass to go you from
Buddy Hill to where they call this time
yes what should buddy dude that's
exactly allottee should to me doesn't
make sense yes but right here buddy just
makes the right decision so that time a
right decision
dropping it to Willie Willie knows what
to do be honest he's got to fight
through that kick but I think that's the
game plan and
you know that if you're Damian seven
assists for Fox to 24 points Kemba
Walker block by cauley-stein
Jenny pushes clips will be haunted back
to yoga really running the floor Willie
cauley-stein beautiful full link to the
court action no-good box who's got
Jackson with him Jackson the trailer and
Willie with a chance at a three-point
play the line nice uh kicked up by the
Aaron [ __ ] the elites ax and yogi
Ferrell Boone's a good work how about
that pass got that Tom I'll let be
inside beautiful pass from shuffle and
what Swilly let's say indeed go by and a
little wham jam on top a big Joelle
indeed indeed that is major Duncan box
has an opening he's okay watch the air
the beautiful little drop-off pass
Willie Cauley right past Whiteside but
gets 15-point lead the biggest of the
game 17:57 bowler Stein with his second
basket Paul to get paint cause there hit
the ball to the other [ __ ] yet to pull
the guy the great people down yep
Winslow's doing a great job on buddy
hill to the right side of your screen
they're betting him from getting the
ball 45 by the sky with a minute 53 left
96 95 he's just just a normal progress
and he'll be there soon
Jackson comes to britches now Johnson
presents out of the game
Green is on the floor Olie Stein from
Fox 109-108 asked a Willie cauley-stein
little brush pick then Willie sets a
beautiful pick get your hand on it the
Willie doesn't jam it there he is
open again that time cauley-stein got it
perfect timing
there's plenty healed 1813 buddy all the
way you need a point per position attack
there's a point and one more
beautiful path right the airin Fox 14 to
8 as the Kings down 60th 7:30 left
cauley-stein again
cauley-stein as eight boys we get a
chance to stay in LA I think for seven
nights oh wow what a pass
hey that's what I like to see from
Willie cauley-stein running the floor
playing above the rim great pass by
Buddy hield first of all year and seeing
buddy leaking out buddies just up top
man Willie Cauley stock-out California
and he has come on defender three and D
type of guy that Danny Ainge hasn't made
a lot of mistakes
built himself a heck of a team that got
draft picks to the Kings to chip into
this a little bit before the half
yes especially with the starting group
nice box the cauley-stein Washington to
big misses last night at the line Pass
was there go off the junket if you don't
make it you're gonna get found just like
that yes
[Applause]
but he'll still able numbers
cauley-stein is with belly the bounce
pass back to a bow but think of beauty
if you don't like that you don't like
kings basketball holy s--t I know a
thing of beauty
watch Willie get the ball here the quick
spin on measure E major throwdown
talking and cauley-stein going back to
that gunk oh what a boat by Willie
cauley-stein fan he's got the incredible
athleticism there it is yeah Bach's
putting it right on the platter no doubt
do the rest Brunson just too small watch
out little dude I'm delivering a heart
piping hot for 45 left and Willie from
Fox yes 43 to 38 slightly with a black
shot New Orleans thought it was
goaltending they don't get the call
cauley-stein with a big dump 49 46 dome
Carli flying at this end pocket pass
duck out watch up oh just a lot out I
will nice
[Applause]
the elites are attacking nice beautiful
setup to cauley-stein yeah great
interior passing by the Kings right
there what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content